okay folks
um
here we are again
welcome back
for another episode of theory of
computation this is lecture number three
um
i
am fir i'm going to review how what
we've been doing um we've been looking
at finite automata
and regular languages those are the
languages that the fine automata can
recognize
and we
talked about
non-determinism so we had
non-deterministic finite automata and
deterministic finite automata we showed
that they're equivalent
we looked at the closure properties over
the regular operations union
concatenation and star and showed that
the
regular language is really the class of
regular languages is closed under those
regular operations
and we used the constructions that we
developed in the proof of those closure
properties to show that the
we can give away to convert
regular expressions to finite automata
so that is uh was
a
part way toward our goal
of showing that these regular
expressions and finite automata are
equivalent with respect to the class of
languages they describe namely the
regular languages so regular expressions
of finite autonomic are interchangeable
from the perspective of what kinds of
languages you can do with them
so we're going to finish that off today
so let's take a look at what
our next
topics we're going to be covering
we're going to
reverse
the
construction that we gave last time
which allowed us to convert regular
expressions to finite automata now we're
going to go backwards we're going to
show how to convert finite automata back
to regular expressions
and um that
those two
constructions together uh show us that
the regular expressions finite automata
can be inter interconverted from one
another and they're therefore equivalent
with respect to the kinds of things they
they can do in language
recognition or generation
then we're going to prove that uh we're
going to look at how you prove certain
languages are not regular they're beyond
the capabilities of fine art automata
and finally at the end we're going to
introduce a new model of computation
which is more powerful
than the finite automata and regular
expressions namely the context-free
grammars
those can do
other kinds of languages that the
simpler find at a time but the regular
expressions models can't do um
and i i would also just like to note
that
a lot of what we're doing is a warm up
toward the more powerful models of
computation that we're going to be
looking at later um well in a week or so
which are
more kind of general purpose
computation
but along the way introducing these
models of finite automata in
context-free languages
is
interesting and helpful because many of
those um a number of those models turn
out to be useful in a number of
applications um whether it's from
you know pro linguistics to
uh programming languages um and a
variety of different uh
parts of computer science and other
fields as well use those notions so
they're they're useful notions um
and beyond just uh
in this course um
okay so
um
i just wanted
a couple of administrative things to
touch on uh we are going to have
additional check-ins today um as i
uh mentioned to you we're gonna start
counting participation not correctness
of just participation in the live
check-ins
so um with that let us
move on to today's material um
as i mentioned we're going to be showing
how to convert
finite automata to regular expressions
um and that's going to complete our
equivalence of finite automata and
regular expressions so just to recap
what we did last time
we showed that if you have a regular
expression
um
uh
and it describes some language then that
language is regular
uh so in other words um we have a way of
we gave a way of converting regular
expressions to finite automata as kind
of shown in this diagram
that's what we did last time
now we're going to go the other way um
we're going to show how to convert oh
and just a reminder in case you're just
getting yourself
your memory size your memory uh to work
um maybe it'll help you just to remember
that we actually did an example of that
conversion we looked at this um regular
expression a union a b star and we
actually worked through the process of
converting that oops i need to make
myself smaller so you can see all that
we went through the process of um
converting a union a b star as an
example of that um
of uh
minimus
okay
uh
well
um
we went through the process of actually
doing that conversion and now we're
going to show how to do it the other way
around
all right so
um
so we're going to invert that
and go backwards the other way
um so today's theorem is to show that if
a is regular namely its
uh um
the language of some finite automaton
um then um
uh
you can convert it to a regular
expression which will describe that same
language so basically we're going to
give a conversion from finite automata
to regular expressions okay um
but before we do that we're going to
have to introduce a new concept um so
we're not going to be able to dive right
into that conversion we're going to have
to do introduce a new model first which
is going to facilitate that conversion
and that new model is called it's in yet
another kind of finite automaton called
a generalized
non-deterministic finite automaton or a
generalized nfa or just simply a gnfa
okay so this is yet another variant of
the finite automaton model um
and
conceptually it's very sim simple it's
similar to the nfas i'll give you here's
a picture of a
gnfa
named
g1 very similar to the nfas but if you
look at it for a second you'll see that
the
transitions have more complicated labels
for the anaphase who are only allowing
just single symbols or the empty string
to appear on the labels now i'm actually
allowing you to put full regular
expressions on the labels
for the automaton
now we have to understand how
a gnfa process as
its input and the way it works is
um not complicated to understand
um
when you're getting an input string
feeding when the when a gnfa is
processing an input string it starts at
the start state just like you would
imagine
but now to go along a transition instead
of reading just a single symbol or the
empty string as a as in the case for the
nondeterministic machine
um
it actually gets to read a whole string
at one step kind of at one byte
it can read an entire string um and go
along that transition um
uh
arrow provided that
trunk of the input that it read
is in the regular expression
that that
uh
transition uh
has as its label
so for example
um
this you can go from q1 to q2 in one
step in this gnfa by reading the by
reading aabb off the input
so it reads all those four symbols all
at once
it just swoops them up and then moves
from q1 to q2
in one step
okay and then when it's in q2
it can read aab
and move to q3 and q3 happens there's
nowhere to go um so this is going to be
a non-deterministic machine there might
be several different ways of processing
the input and if any one of them gets to
an accepting state at the end of the
input
we say the gnfa accepts
so it's similar to non-deterministic to
nfa's in in the way the acceptance
criterion works
um so you know you could do an example
but hopefully the concept of how this
works is reasonably
you know you can at least buy it um that
it processes
um the input in
chunks at a time and those chunks have
to be described by the
uh regular expressions on the transition
our arrows as it moves along those
transitions
okay
so um
what we're going to do
now
is to convert
not
dfas to regular expressions we're going
to convert gnfas to regular expression
that's even harder
because gnfas are allow you to do all
sorts of other things besides just
ordinary dfas
so that's a harder job why am i making
my life harder well you'll see in a
minute
that it's going to actually turn out to
be helpful to be working with a more
powerful model um
in the way this construction is going to
work
okay
now before i dive in and do the
construction from gnfas to regular
expressions i'm going to make a
simplifying assumption about the g
anaphase
i'm going to put them in a special form
that's going to make it easier to do the
conversion
and that simpler form is
first of all i'm going to assume that
gnfa has just a single accepting state
and that accepting state is not allowed
to be the start state
okay so it has to have just a single
accepting state i've already violated
that um convenient assumption in this
gnfa because i have here two
uh accepting states that's not what i
want i want to have just one
well the thing is it's easy to obtain
just one just to modify the machine so
that i have just one by
adding a new accepting state which is
branch two from the former accepting
states by empty transition so i can
always jump from q2 to q4 at any time
without even reading any input just
going along this empty transition
and then i declassify the former
accepting states as accepting
and now i have here just a single
accepting state and
because it's going to be a new state
that i added it won't be the start state
and i have
accomplished that one aspect of my
assumption about the form of the gnfa
but there's another thing that i want to
do too
i want to assume
um as you'll see which is going to be
convenient in my uh
construction that we will have
transition arrows going from every state
to every other state in fact i want
transition i was going from every state
even back to themselves
um
i want the there to be all of all
possible transition arrows should be
present
um
uh with with two exceptions
uh for for the start state there should
be only transition arrows exiting the
start state
and for the accepting state there's just
one now there should be only transition
arrows coming in to the start state
so it's kind of what you would imagine
as being reasonable um for the other
states which are not accepting or or um
starting
there should be
transition arrows leaving and coming
from everywhere else but for the start
states just leaving and from the except
state just coming in
and you could easily modify the machine
to achieve that um let's just see how to
do that in one example so from notice
that from q3 to q2 there is no
transition right now and that's not good
that's not what i want i want that to be
a transition from q3 to q2 well i'll
just add that transition in
but i'm going to label it with the empty
language regular expression
so that means yeah the transition is
there but you never can take it
so it doesn't change
the
language that the machine is going to be
recognizing but it fulfills my um
uh
my assumption my convenient assumption
that we have all of these transition
arrows being present in the machine
okay so uh
anyway i hope you uh will buy it it's
not gonna be re if you don't quite get
this don't worry it's not totally
critical that you're following or these
little these little adjustments and
modifications to the gnf8 but it will be
helpful to understand what gnf
themselves how they work
so as i mentioned we can easily modify
gnfa to have the special form that we're
assuming here
all right so now we're going to jump in
and start doing the conversion so we're
going to have a lemma which is like a a
theorem that really is just a local
interest here it's not a
general interest theorem it's going to
be relevant just to gnfa which it really
just defined to help us do this
conversion they really don't have any
other independent value
so every you want to show that every g n
of a has an equivalent regular
expression r
that's really my goal um
and the way we're going to prove that
is by induction
it's going to be by induction on the
number of states of the gnfa
now
you really should be familiar with
induction as one of the uh expectations
for being in this course but in case
you're a little shaky on it don't worry
i'm gonna unpack it um as a procedure
it's really just recursion you know
induction is just a and a proof that
uses induction is really just a proof
that calls itself it's just a proof that
it's a recursive proof that's all it is
so if you're comfortable with the
recursion you'll be comfortable with
induction um but anyway i'm going to
describe this as a procedure so if
you're a little shaky on induction don't
worry
um
so the basis is so first i'm going to
handle the case where the gnfa has just
two states
okay um
now remember i'm assuming now my gnfas
are in the special form
so you can't even have a gnfa with one
state because it has to have a start
state and it has to have an accept state
and they have to not be the same so the
smallest possible gnfa to worry about is
a two-state gnfa
okay now if we have a if we happen to
have a two-state gnfa it turns out to be
very easy to find the equivalent regular
expression why
because
that tuesday gnfa can only look like
this
it can have a start state can have an
accept state
and it can only have a transition going
from the start to the accept because no
other transitions are
allowed um it only has outgoing from the
start only incoming from the uh
to the except and so there's only one
transition and it has a label with a
regular expression r
so what do you think the equivalent
regular expression is for this g nfa
it's just simply the one that's labeling
that transition because that tells us
when i can go from the start to the
accept and there's nothing else the
machine can do it just makes one step
which is to accept its input if it's
described by that regular expression so
therefore the equivalent regular
expression that we're looking for is
simply label on that single transition
okay so two state g nfas are easy
um but what if what happens if you have
more states then you're gonna actually
have to do some work
um
so
we call that the induction step that's
when we have more than two states
and what that the way the induction
works is we're going to assume we
already know how to do it for k minus 1
states
and we're going to use that knowledge to
show how to do it for k-states
so in other words um we already know how
to do it for two states
i'm going to use that fact to show how
to do it for three states
and then use the fact that i can do it
for three states to show how to do it
for four states and so on and so on
all right
and the idea for how to do that is
actually uh
pretty
uh easy to to grasp
um what we're going to do is if we have
a k-state gnfa that we want to convert
we're going to con we're going to change
that k state g n of a to a k minus 1
state g n of a
and then use our assumption that we
already know how to do the k minus 1
state g nfa
all right
so um
in terms of a picture i'm going to take
a k-state to prove that i can always
convert k-state g-n-phase uh to regular
expressions
i'm going to show how to convert the
k-state um one into an equivalent k
minus one state g of a and then if you
just like to think of it this
procedurally the k minus one will gets
converted to a k minus two gets
converted to a k minus three and so on
and so on until i get down to two
which then i know how to do directly
okay so the whole name of the game here
is figuring out how to convert a
gnfa that has k states
into another one that has one fewer
state that does the same language
okay so you have to
hold that in your head i mean i wish i
had more blackboard space here but you
know it's very limited here so you have
to remember what would what we're going
to be doing on the next slide
because that's going to finish the job
for us as long as i can show in general
how to convert a k-state gnfa to a gnfa
that is one fewer state but it still
does the same language
i'm good
because then i can keep iterating that
till i get down to two
all right
so here is um
this is the
the guts of the argument um so i have my
k-state machine here's my my start state
here's my accept state
um here's my k minus one state that
machine that i'm going to be uh building
for you it's actually going to be
be look almost exactly the same i'm just
going to remove one state
um
from the from the from the bigger
machine
so i'm going to pick any state which is
not the
start state or the accept state um here
it is pictured here
i mean all of the states of the k-state
machine are going to appear in the k-1
state machine
except for one state that i'm going to
rip out
okay
that's the state x it's now here as a
ghost
it's been removed
um
uh it's not there anymore okay but i'm
just helping you to remember that used
to be there
by showing his shadow
but it's a
uh i have taken
my original machine that had k-states
um
and basically just ripped out of state
um and now i've
you know one fewer state
so the good news
is that i now have a machine with k
minus one states
that's what i want
but the bad news is that it doesn't do
the same language anymore
it's i i broke the machine by rip just
if you're just going to rip out a state
you know who knows what the machine is
going to do it's going to be
probably not the same as what the
original machine did
so what i need to do
then
is repair the damage
i've got to fix the damage that i caused
by removing
x okay um
and
whatever
role
x was playing
in the original machine
i've got to make sure
that
the the new machine that i have which
doesn't have x anymore can still do the
same things
um that the original machine did
um and so the way i'm going to do that
is look at all of the paths that could
go through x and make sure that they're
still present even though i don't have x
anymore
and the way i'm going to do that is i'm
going to take
um
[Music]
consider
a part of a path that might use x
so it starts
let's pick two states q i and two j
in the uh machine that had k states
let me just here
i know this is uh
okay um
we have if we have uh we'll pick two
states q i and q j
um in in in the original machine now qi
might
have the possibility of going to state x
and then x might have a self loop
and then it might go to 2j
the new machine doesn't have any x
anymore
the way i'm going to fix that
is by
replacing the label that goes directly
from i to j
with a new label
that
adds in all of the things i lost
when i removed x
okay that's
that's the whole idea here so here is q
i to q j but there's no x anymore
how could i get
from q i to q j
um
um you know
you know what what were the
inputs
that could have brought us from qi to qj
via x
well they would have been an input
that read a string described by r1
i might have self-looped at x a few
times
so i might have read several strings
that are described by r2
and then i would have read a string that
was described by r3 and now i'm at qj
okay
so
uh the new label
that i'm going to place over here is
going to be
uh the strings that i get from reading
are one you know reading a a
a
a string that described by r1
then multiple copies of a stretch you
know
multiple strings that are possibly
describing r2 which is the same as r2
star
or and then multiples and then a string
that would be described by r3
so that is a new addition to the
transition that takes me from q i to q j
of course i need to include the things
that would have taken me from q i to q j
in the first place
so i'm also unioning in r4 what was the
direct route from qy to qj that did not
uh transit through x
okay
so by making that
uh
uh
you know
new
um regular expression
on the q i to q j transition
i have compensated for the loss of x
for paths that go from q i to x
and then
out to q j now what i
need to do
is to
do that same thing for every pair qi and
qj
that are in the original machine
and so if i do that for every possible
pair
i'll be modifying all of the transitions
in the new machine
in a way
that
[Music]
compensates for the loss of x and now
the new machine has been repaired from
the damage that i caused by removing x
and it does the same language
it's kind of thing you need to think a
little bit about i understand um but at
least hopefully uh the uh the spirit
of what i just described to you uh comes
through that we're going to convert this
case machine with k states to one with
uh k minus one states by removing a
state and repairing the damage
and now it does the same language and
then i can remove another state and do
the same thing over and over again until
i get down to two states
okay so that's the um
idea and that really completes uh the
proof
that shows
that i can
uh
convert every gnfa
to a regular expression
okay um
and that really is uh the end of the
story for this um
and thus
i claim that dfas now and regular
expressions are equivalent
so let me get going to give you a little
check in here on this
uh
um
really just to see
if high level if you're following what's
going on
all right
uh so just take a look so we just showed
how to convert g n of a to regular
expression but we really wanted to
convert dfas to regular expressions so
how do we go from g n f converting g n
of a is to converting dfas because
they're not the same obviously right um
so how do we finish that
so there are three choices here
first we have to try to convert dfa to g
interface maybe or sure to convert gnfa
to df dfas or maybe we're already done
so maybe i better launch that poll while
you're while you're reading that
um
and there you
go hopefully you can
um all right
why don't i end this it's a little
worrying worrisome because uh i would
say we have a plurality who got the
right answer but not a majority uh
so uh let us share the results um i
think
so uh i sense not all of you are with me
um
but uh um you're gonna have to uh
uh
tr either that or you're
you know you're uh playing you're
reading your email while we're uh
talking i'm not sure but um
whatever it is um
you
need to think a little bit about what's
going on here because
um
what
you know the reason why we are done
is because dfas are a kind of g-n-phase
they're just they have a very simple
kind of regular expression on each
transition
um they
just have the regular expression which
is just a single symbol
so all dfas are automatically gnaphase
so if i can convert g anaphase i can
certainly convert dfas because dnf's
include the dfas i'm done it really was
number c
was the correct answer
okay
it's a good thing we're not
counting
uh
correctness here so participation is
good enough but i do think you need to
think about what's going on and making
sure that you're you know you're you're
you're following along so anyway that's
a uh
um
you know we'll carry on here but um
makes me a little concerned um
okay uh so um let us now move on um so
we're going to talk a little bit about
non-regular languages
um
so somebody's asking don't we have to
still make the dfas into the special
type yes we do we have to make them to
the special type but we already showed
how to make g interface into the special
type and dfa that that is going to apply
to dfas as well um
you know they'll become
gnfas you know you can add the extra
starts
at a new start state and at a new uh
accept state
add in all the transitions with which
you didn't have before with the empty
language
label
and you'll have a gnfa
from um a dfa but that applies to
gnaphase as a in general so it's nothing
special about dfas there anyway
uh i think you need to chew on that
hopefully uh you know you're you'll be
uh following going forward anyway let us
look now at non-proving non-regularity
so we're finished with our goal
of showing that regular languages that
the regular languages can either come
from
dfas or from regular expressions those
are the same in terms of from the
perspective of our course they're
interchangeable
okay so now uh
as we mentioned there are going to be
some languages which are not regular
which can't be done by dfas uh their
actual dfas are actually pretty weak as
a computational model and so there's all
sorts of very simple things that they
cannot do um
uh those there are some fairly
complicated things that they can do
surprisingly enough
but anyway um
there are some simple things they can't
do and so we have to develop a method
for showing that a language is not
regular um and that's going to be useful
for your homework um and in general for
just understanding the uh the power of
dfas
so how do we show our language is not
regular so
remember if you want to show a language
is regular basically what you need to do
is give a dfa
or you know you can use the closure
properties that's another way of showing
a language is regular but underneath
that it's basically constructing dfas
all right um to show a language is not
regular you have to give a proof
uh generally not a construction it's a
proof that there is no uh dfa or that
whatever uh that it's just going to be
impossible to make a dfa um
and we have to develop a method what
what is that proof method
um now
there is a tempting um
you know i've taught this course many
times and there's a kind of attempting
approach
uh that many people have um it's not
only going to apply for finite automata
but for other things too and believe me
it's not only
people in this class it's for people uh
out there in the um who are trying to
think about computation in general
which is to say
well you know
um
uh
you know i have some language of trying
to figure out if it's regular or not and
so i thought really hard how to make a
dfa and i couldn't find one therefore
it's not regular
that's that's not that's not a proof
just because you couldn't find a dfa
doesn't mean there is no dfa
you need to prove
that the language is not regular using
some method
um so i'm going to give you an example
where that kind of approach can lead you
wrong
and that is i'll give two examples
of
languages where
you might
try to prove they're regular or not and
you could be uh
in trouble if you just follow uh that
kind of informal approach
so if you take the language b
where these are string well let's assume
our alphabet is zeros and ones uh
b is the language of all strings that
have an equal number of zeros and ones
um
uh so you wanna know you know if i have
a thousand zeros i need to have a
thousand ones so basically the way you
test that you'd have to count up the
number of zeros count up the number of
ones
and see if those two counts are the same
and that's going to be really tough to
make a dfa do
um because it's you know how you're
going to remember such you know that
really big number of zeros that you know
the dfa might have 50 states but you
might need to count up to a hundred or a
million to figure out to count up how
many um
zeros you've seen
and it seems really hard to be able to
do that kind of account when you only
have 50 states uh some so whatever
number of states you have it's you're
not it seems hard to count uh when you
have a lim when you have a finite
automaton so the intuition is it's not
regular because a finite atomic done
can't count um which
in this case
you can convert that intuition into a
real proof i would say it's not a real
proof yet
but it can be made into a real proof
um
but compare that case with another
language which i'll call c
which instead of uh looking at its input
to see whether it has an equal number of
zeros and ones i'm going to look at the
input and look at the substrings of zero
ones and one zeros those two substrings
and count the number of occurrences of
zero one as a substring and the number
of occurrences of one zero as a
substring
okay just to make sure you're
understanding let's look at some
examples uh two examples
so the string zero one zero one
is not going to be in c
because if you count up the number of
zero ones and the number of one zeros
not the same so i'm even going to help
you here uh if you can see that the
number of zero ones is two
but there's uh
there's only a single occurrence of one
zero
okay so those are those two
counts are different
and so that's why this input string is
not in c
compare that with the string
zero one one zero
now if you count up the number of zero
one and one zero sub strings you're
going to get the same value because here
we have a single zero one and a single
one zero
and so now the two counts of those
number of substrings are the same
and so that's why you're in c
okay
now my question is
is c a regular language
well it looks like it shouldn't be
regular for the same reason that b is in
regular because you have to count up two
quantities and and compare them
um
so um
uh
now
um
so
if we
um
you know so that's our intuition that
you just can't do it for the with a
finite automaton because you have to do
the same kind of counting that you would
have had to do for language b
but here
you'll be you would be wrong
because c in fact is regular
um
uh
it has a much
simpler description
than the one i gave over here uh at the
beginning there's a the there's the very
same language c can be described in a
much much simpler way i'm not going to
tell you what it is you can mull that
over you can try some examples uh to
figure it out but it has a much simpler
description it's not totally trivial
description i mean there is some content
there but there is um you know it is the
kind of thing that a finite automaton
can do it wouldn't do the counting this
way um
so the moral is the punch line is that
sometimes the intuition works but it can
also be wrong
um and so the moral of the stories you
need to give a proof when you're when
you're doing things like that
okay
so what we're going to do next in the
second half of the lecture
is to give a method for proving
languages are not regular and again
you're going to need to use that on your
homework so i hope you get it um but uh
first of all oh did i
never stop sharing that poll forgive me
um
and so
uh
um
and so with that i think we'll take our
little requested break
uh
and um for five minutes
and uh
we'll be back in five minutes
um
so
break time
alrighty
we are done here
and um
proving languages not regular
okay
um
[Music]
the way we're going to prove languages
are not regular is by introducing um a
method called the pumping lemma
um
and the overarching plan at the pumping
lemma without getting into the
specifics of it
is to say show that
um
um that lemma says
all
regular languages have a certain
property
which we will describe
and so
to show a language is not regular
you simply show the language doesn't
have that property
um because
all regular languages have to have that
property and so by showing a language
fails to have the property it could not
be regular
okay that's that's the plan
um
now uh
the property itself
is a little complicated um to describe
um but not too bad i'll try to unpack it
for you
but first let's look at the statement of
dilemma
um
which says that
whenever you have a regular language
let's call it a so for every regular
language a
there's always a special value
called the pump
a number uh p we'll call it called the
pumping length
okay it's a special number and
uh
uh it's um
and
that
uh
uh
that length
um
uh
tells you
that
whenever a string is in that language
and it's longer than that length
then um
something special happens
you can take that string and you can
modify it and you still stay in the
language so anything that's longer than
that special length can be modified in a
certain way and you still say in the
language so let's look at the the actual
um statement of the lemma
so
there is a number p
such that if s is a string in the
language and it's longer than p or at
least of length p
then you can take s and you can cut it
up into three pieces x y and z
so they're just breaking s into three
pieces
where
um
you can take that middle piece
repeat it as many times as you like
and you're still staying the language
because that's the
uh
what the pumping llama is saying and
there's a bunch of other conditions here
too but
the the spirit of the pumping lumber
says whenever you have a regular
language there's some cut off such that
all strings longer than that cut off
can be what we call pumped you can take
that string you can find a section
somewhere in the middle of that string
or somewhere you cut it up in three
piece pieces you take them
that center piece and you can repeat it
you can pump it up
um and
by repeating that string and repeating
that piece the string gets longer and
longer
but you still stay in the language um
that's the special property that all
regular languages have
so kind of in an informal way and we'll
do so i'll try to help you get the
feeling for this um formally it says
that
you know if you have a regular language
then every long string so as long as by
informing my informal way of saying
bigger than this value p every long
string in the language can be pumped
and this result still stays in the
language and by pumped means i can cut
the string into three pieces and repeat
that middle piece as many times as i
want that's what i mean by pumping a
string
um
[Music]
so uh
uh we'll do some examples uh in a second
um
but first we're going to un see how to
prove this and hopefully that will give
you some feeling
also for why it's true
so
uh and actually maybe before i actually
jump into the proof let me let's look at
these three conditions here just to
understand it a little bit more uh
uh thoroughly
uh so condition one kind of says what i
just uh was was telling you
um i can break s into three pieces x y z
such that if i take x
y to the i z
so that's repeating y as many times as i
want so here's y to the i kind of
defined if that's helpful to you it's
just y i copies of y so i can take x y
to the i z and i remain in in the
language for every value of i even i
equals zero which means we're just
removing y uh which is sometimes
actually a useful thing to do but you
know
let's not get ahead of ourselves
um you know so
if
um you know
you know i can cut s i can i'm
guaranteed to be able to cut s up into x
y z so that the string x y y y is still
on the language or x y y y y y it's
still in the language um that's going to
be guaranteed for every regular language
that's good that's that's a feature
that's going to be true
um and furthermore and this is going to
be turning out to be it's not really
kind of part of the core idea of the
pumping lamb but it actually turns out
to be very helpful in applying the
pumping lemma
you can always cut it up in such a way
that the first two pieces are not longer
than that value p
um so this
it restricts on the ways you can cut the
thing up and that actually turns out to
be very helpful
um but let's first just look at the
proof of this uh giving kind of a little
bit the high level picture
um
so
my job is to show if i have a have a
string in my language let's say
think of it as a long string really long
um so it's length is more than p but i
think intuitively it's just a very long
string um
and i'm going to feed that string into
the machine
and watch what happens
something special happens when i feed
the string and i look at how the machine
proceeds
on that string
um
because
s is
so long
that
as i wander around inside the machine i
end have to end up coming back to the
same place more than once
um it's like you know if you have a
small park and you go for a long walk
you're going to end up coming back to
wave or what you've already seen you
just can't keep on seeing new stuff when
you have a more small area of space to
explore
so
um
so we're guaranteed that m is going to
end up repeating some state when it's
reading s because s is so long
so in terms pictorially um if you
imagine here this wiggly line is kind of
describing the path that m follows when
it's reading s it ends up coming back to
that state q j more than once so it
comes back here cycles around comes back
again before it ends up accepting we
know what it ends up accepting because
we're assuming we have a string that's
in the language so we picked s in the
language so it has to be accepted by m
but the important thing is that it
repeats a state
now um
how does that tell me i can cut s up
into those three pieces
well i'm going to get those three pieces
here um first of all let's observe that
here is a process you know as processing
s here is the that
written right on top of the string that
state repetition occurring uh qj more
than once and now if i look inside the
machine the part of s that took me
to q j i'm going to call x
the part that took me from q j back to
itself is i'm going to call y and the
partner took qj
to the accept state i'm going to call z
and i'm going to mark those often in s
and that gives me the way to cut s up
into three pieces
um
now
if you're appreciating
um what's going on inside the machine
you will see
why
m will also accept the string x y y
z
because
every time you know once you're at q j
you know if you go around once you come
back to q j and then if you go again
you'll come back to q j and as many
times as you keep seeing that y you're
just going to keep coming back to q j
so
it doesn't matter how many
y's you have you're going to still if
you follow it by z which is what you'll
do you'll end up accepting the string
um
and that's really the proof um i mean
you have to do a little bit more um
uh here just to understand i i should
have mentioned why i want to forbid y
being the empty string because if it was
the empty string it's not interesting it
doesn't change uh
um you know repeating it doesn't
actually change anything so i have to
make sure it's not empty but anyway
that's kind of a detail here
uh if you look at the string x y y z
that's still going to be accepted
okay so that's the proof of the pumping
lemma
all right uh so let's have a little
check-in uh related to that uh this is
not gonna be again not super hard but uh
um
more just a curiosity uh
uh
so the pumping alignment depends on the
fact that if m has p states and it runs
for more than p steps then it's going to
enter some state twice
so you may have seen that before it
actually has a name
um which some of you may have seen um
so let's see how to just get a poll here
and
i hope not too many of you are gonna
pick c i said some of you are oh well
uh yes
i think this one most of you are
you've seen this before
this is um
i think you pretty much all got it um
this is what's known as the pigeonhole
principle
uh so
you know here uh sharing the results uh
obviously i was having a little fun with
this and sure some of you are having fun
back at me that's okay
um
okay so let's continue on um let's see
how to use the pumping lemma
to
prove the language is not regular um so
i put the pumping limb up here just uh
so you can remember the statement of it
um
uh so let's take the language d which is
the language
0 to the k1 to the k
for any k so that's
some number of zeros followed by an
equal number of ones
we're going to prove that language is
not regular by using the pumping lemma
okay and this is going to be just an
iron-clad
proof it's not going to say well i
couldn't think of how to find you know i
you know i couldn't think of how to find
a finite automaton this is going to be
you know this is going to really uh be a
proof
okay so we want to show that d is not
regular
uh
and we're going to give uh these things
always go as a proof by contradiction so
proof by contradiction hopefully as a
reminder to you the way that works is
you're going to assume the opposite of
what you're trying to prove
and then
uh from that something crazy is going to
happen something you know is obviously
false or wrong
and so therefore your assumption which
is the opposite of what you were trying
to prove had to be wrong and so
therefore the thing you're trying to
prove has to be right
um that's the essence of what's called
proof by contradiction
so first of all we're going to assume to
get our contradiction that is regular
um
and which is what we're trying to show
is not the case
now if the is regular then we can apply
the pumping lamp
um up above here uh which
gives us that pumping length p
which says that any string longer than p
can be pumped and you stay in the
language that's what the pumping limit
tells you
so let's pick the string s
uh which is the string zero to the p one
to the p here's sort of a picture of s
off on the side here so a bunch of zeros
followed by an equal number of ones
and that string is in d
because d is
strings of that form
and it's longer than p
obviously it's a blank 2p
so the pumping limit tells us there's a
way to cut it up
um satisfying those three conditions
so how in the world could we
possibly cut s s up well remember the
three conditions and especially
condition three is going to come in
handy here
say that you can cut s up into three
pieces x y and z
where the first two pieces lie in the
first
uh
p
uh symbols of s
um
you know at most
p long
so x and y together are not very big
they don't extend beyond the first half
of x
and first half of s and in particular
they're all zeros
x and y are going to be all zeros z is
going to perhaps have some zeros and
we'll have the rest of the ones we'll
have the ones
um now um
uh
the pumping limit says if you cut it up
that way you can repeat why as many
times as you like and you stay in the
language but that's obviously false
because if you repeat y which is now has
only zeros you're going to have too many
zeros
and so the resulting string is no longer
going to be of the form 0 to the k 1 to
the k it's going to be
lots of zeros followed by not so many
ones that's not in the language and that
violates what the pumping limit tells
you is supposed to happen
and that's a contradiction
so therefore our assumption that d is
regular is false
and so we conclude that d is not regular
so that's a fairly simple one
i thought i would do another couple of
examples because you have this on your
homework and i thought it might be
helpful so here's the second one
slightly harder but not too much
let's take the language f which is
looks like this strings ww
um these are strings that uh two copies
of the same string
um
for any string uh that might be in sigma
star so for any string at all i'm going
to have two copies of that string and so
f is those strings can which can be
which are just you know two copies of
the same string
uh
okay we're going to show that f is not
regular these things always go the same
way it's the same pattern you prove by
contradiction so you assume for a
contradiction that oh d that's bad
uh
that was copied from my other slide
that's wrong let's see if i can actually
make this work here
good
assume for a contradiction that f is
regular
the pumping limit gives f is above and
so now we need to choose a string s
that's in f
okay to do the pumping and show that
the pumping lemma is going to fail
um you know it's you're going to pump
and you're going to get something which
is not in language which is uh
you know shows that the pump is
something has gone wrong but which s to
choose and and sometimes that's where
the creativity in applying the pumping
lemma
comes in
because you have to figure out which is
the right string you're going to pump on
um so you know you might try the string
well
0 to the p 0 to the p that's certainly
in f
it's two copies of the same string
here it is i've written
you know uh
um
lots of zeros followed by the same
number of zeros
the problem is if you use that string
um
[Music]
it actually
uh is a string that you can pump you can
break that string up into three pieces
and then if you let
uh y be the string zero zero that you
have to be a little careful just the
string just zero it doesn't work because
there's an evenness oddness phenomenon
going here so you might want to just
think about that but if you let this y
be the string 0 0
then if you have the string x
y
x any number of y's it's still just
going to be a bunch of zeros and you're
going to be able to see that that string
is still in the language so you haven't
learned anything
if the pumping lemon works
and and you're
satisfying the pumpkin you haven't you
haven't learned anything
so
what you need to find is some other
string
so that was a bad choice for s
find a different string so here's a
different choice 0 to the p1 0 to the p1
so that's two copies of the same string
and you're going to show it can't be
we're going to show it can't be pumped
so here's a picture of that string here
so 0 is followed by 1 0's followed by 1.
and now it's very similar to the first
argument
if you cut it into three pieces in such
a way that it satisfies the conditions
the first two pieces are going to be
residing only among the zeros and so
therefore when you repeat
a y um
you're no longer going to have two
copies of the same string um and so
won't be in the language so therefore
you've got a contradiction and f is not
regular so you have to i you have to
play with the pumping lemma a little bit
if you haven't seen that before it's
going to be
you know it takes a little getting used
to but you have a few homework questions
that need to be solved using the pumping
level all right so now um
let's look at uh
lastly there is another method that can
come in which is combining closure
properties with the pumping lemma
so closure properties sometimes help you
so let's look at the language b which is
actually we saw earlier in the lecture
where we have an equal number of zeros
and ones
now we could prove that directly using
the pumping lemma as not being regular
but it's actually even easier
um
uh what we're going to prove
uh that it
we're going to prove that it's not
regular in a different way first we're
going to assume for contradiction as we
often do that it is regular um
and now we're going to use something
we're going to use some other knowledge
we're not going to use the pumping llama
here um because we're going to take
advantage of an earlier case where we
use the pumping level
and so um
now we know that the string the language
0 star 1 star is a regular language
because it's described by a regular
expression if you take the
b
which is the equal numbers of zeros and
ones
and you intersect it with zero star one
star
that's going to be a regular language if
b was regular
using closure under intersection
but this language b intersect zero star
one star
is the language
of
equal numbers of zeros and ones where
the zeros come first
and that's the language d that we show
two slides back
that we already know can't be regular
so that intersection cannot be regular
and so it violates the closure property
um
and again we get a contradiction
uh so
um that's a different way of
sometimes making a shortcut
to prove a language is not regular
okay
so we have in our last uh ten minutes or
so we're going to shift gears totally in
an entirely different way and consider a
new model of computation uh which is
more powerful that can actually do
things that we can't do with a with
finite automata and these are called
context-free grammars so this is really
just a kind of an introduction
we're going to spend uh all of next
lecture uh looking at context-free
grammars um and their associated
languages uh but let's just to kind of
get us
get a preview
so a context-free grammar looks like
this you have a bunch of these
um
uh
um what we call substitution rules or
rules sometimes
would just look like a symbol arrow a
string of symbols
all right
that's what a context-free grammar looks
like at a high level
let's define some terms um
so a rule as i just described is uh
going to be look it's going to be a
symbol which we're going to call a
variable
um and that's going to have an arrow to
a string of other possibly other
variables and
symbols called terminals
um
so a variable is a symbol that appears
on the left hand side of a rule
anything that appears on the left hand
side is going to be considered to be a
very ver a variable um
okay
so s and r are both variables
um
now
other symbols that appear in the grammar
which don't appear in the in in the
left-hand side
those
are going to be called terminals
so here 0 and 1 are terminals
now you may think that empty string
should also be a terminal but that's not
a symbol an empty string is a string
it's just a string of length zero so i'm
not considering empty string to be a
terminal
so
and then there's going to be a special
variable which is going to be considered
the starting variable just like we had a
starting state and that's typically
going to be written as the top left
symbol so this symbol s here is going to
be the starting symbol
and grammars can be used to
uh define languages
and to gen well to generate strings and
to define languages so first of all
let's see how
a grammar using this as an illustration
can generate strings um
actually just to emphasize this uh these
terminology here in this particular
example we had three rules
uh the two variables were r and s the
two terminals were zero and one
and the start variable was this top
left-hand symbol as i mentioned the s
okay
so grammars generate strings the way
they do is
you follow a certain procedure which is
really pretty simple
you
write down first of all the starts
variable and i'll do an example in a
second
you write down the start variable
and then you take a look what you've
written down
and if it has any variables in it you
can
apply
one of the corresponding right hand
sides of a rule
um
to as a substitution for that variable
and so like for example if you have an s
in the thing you've written down you can
substitute for that s a zero s one
or you can substitute for that s and r
or if you have an r you can substitute
for that's an empty string
so you're just going to keep on doing
that substitutions over and over again
until there are no variables left so
there's nothing left to substitute
only terminals remain
at that point you have generated a
string in the language
okay so the language then is the
collection of all generated strings
okay let's do an example here's an
example of g1 generating some string so
as i mentioned first of all you're going
to write down the start variable
and i'm just going to illustrate this in
sort of two parallel tracks here
on the left side i'm going to show you
the tree of substitutions and on the
right side i'm going to show you the
resulting string that you get by
applying those substitutions
okay
so over here i'm going to substitute for
s the string 0 s1 so on the right hand
side i just have 0 s1 because that's
what i substituted for s but you'll see
it's not going to it's going to look a
little different in a second
here i'm going to again i still have a
variable so i'm going to substitute for
s 0 s 1.
now i have the string resulting string 0
0 s 1 1 because i've substituted 0 s 1
for the previous s but the 0 and 1 stick
around from before they don't go
anywhere so i have at this point 0 0 s 1
1. now
uh i'm going to take a different choice
i'm going to substitute for s you know i
could have gone either way this sort of
something like almost like
non-determinism here because you have a
choice
uh i'm going to substitute for s um
instead of 0 s1 i'm going to substitute
r because that's also legitimate in
terms of the rules
and so now i'm going to have
0 0 r
1 1.
and now r has there's no choices here r
can only be substituted for by an empty
string
so i get to r becomes just empty string
and in terms of the string generated
empty string doesn't add anything it
just really is
nothing it's a nothing so i get the
string 0 0 1 1 and this is a string just
of terminal symbols
and so that is a string in the language
of
the grammar g1
okay
if you think about it g1's language is
that language that we saw before uh
which i think we called
d
um
zero to the k one to the k for k greater
than or equal to zero so this is an
example of the language that a
context-free grammar can do but i find
that automaton cannot do
okay
so that is our little introduction to
con oops there's one more check in here
um
oh yeah so i'm asking you to actually
look at
let me get myself a look out of this
picture
um
so you
don't see me blocking things
and we will do one last check-in
make sure you're staying around for the
whole thing
now you can now there could be several
of these strings that are in the
language you have to click them all
all the ones that you have found that
are in the language of this grammar that
can be generated by grammar g2
you have to click those i'll give you a
little bit more time on this one um
to see which ones uh g2 can generate
um
i'll give you a hint it's more than one
but not all
uh
so i see you're making some progress
here
um
interesting
so please uh we're gonna wrap this up
very quickly
uh you can't call us somebody's telling
me you can't unclick thank you good to
know
um
[Music]
okay so still things are coming in here
so
uh
let's not we're we're running toward the
end of the hour here i don't want to go
over so i'm going to end it in five
seconds
uh click away and don't forget
uh
we're not uh going to charge you if you
get it wrong um
sharing results
uh
i don't know why it has an orange one
there because
there are several correct answers here
um
so it's a b and d are correct
um you can get any of any of those um
it's really sort of two copies of the
language we had before
uh next to one another uh
and so
um
the only thing you cannot get is
one zero one zero
um so i encourage you to think about
that
and i will uh
uh
come to our last side of today um which
is just a quick review um
i can put myself back
so we show how to convert dfas to
regular expressions
and the summary is that dfas nfas
gnfas even ray and regular expressions
are all equivalent um in the class of
languages they can describe
uh
the second thing we did was a method for
proving languages not regular by using
the pumping lemma or closure properties
and lastly we introduced context-free
grammars and we're going to see more
about those on thursday
so with that i think we're out of time
and
other thank you for the
notes of appreciation and um
i will um
i think we're gonna
end here um and uh
see you
um on thursday if not before